humans want to believe so much that
people think the large language models
are conscious that's how much humans
want to believe
strong war is he's throwing left and
right hooks uh why do you think large
language models are not conscious I
don't think God just
oh so what is consciousness then George
cost it's like what it seems to mean to
people it's just like a word that
atheists use for Souls
sure but that doesn't mean soul is not
an interesting word
if Consciousness is a spectrum I'm
definitely way more conscious than the
large language models are
I think the large language models are
less conscious than a chicken
when's the last time you've seen a
chicken
how you know like a living chicken just
living chickens walking around yeah it's
crazy
like on the street yeah like a chicken a
chicken yeah all right
all right I was trying to call you all
like a good journalist and I uh I got
shut down
okay but uh you don't
think much about this kind of
subjective feeling that it it feels like
something
to exist and then as an observer
you can
have a sense that an entity is not only
intelligent but has a kind of
subjective experience of its reality
like a self-awareness that is capable of
like suffering of hurting of being
excited by the environment in a way
that's not merely uh
kind of an artificial response but a
deeply felt one humans want to believe
so much that if I took a rock and a
Sharpie and Drew a sad face on the Rock
they'd think the rock is sad
yeah
and you're saying when we look in the
mirror we we apply the same smiley face
with rock pretty much yeah doesn't that
isn't that weird though that you're not
conscious is that no
but you do believe in Consciousness not
really it's just it's unclear okay so to
you it's like a little like a a symptom
of the bigger thing that's not that
important yeah I think it's interesting
that like the human systems seem to
claim that they're conscious and I guess
it kind of like says something in a
straight up like okay what do people
mean when even if you don't believe in
Consciousness what do people mean when
they say Consciousness and there's
definitely like meanings to it what's
your favorite thing to eat
pizza cheese pizza what are the toppings
I like cheese pizza don't say pineapple
okay pepperoni because they put any Ham
on it oh it's real bad what's the best
what's the best pizza what are we
talking about here like you like cheap
crappy Pizza Chicago deep dish cheese
pizza oh that's that's my favorite there
you go you bite into a deep dish Chicago
deep dish pizza and it feels like so you
were starving you haven't eaten oh yeah
for 24 hours you just bite in and you're
hanging out with somebody that matters a
lot to you and you're there with the
pizza sounds real nicer yeah all right
it feels like something I'm I'm George
Hots eating a
Chicago deep dish pizza there's just the
full Peak like living experience yeah of
Being Human the top of the Human
Condition sure
it feels like something to experience
that
why does it feel like something that's
Consciousness isn't it
if that's the word you want to use to
describe it sure I'm not going to deny
that that feeling exists I'm not going
to deny that I experienced that feeling
when I guess what I kind of take issue
to is that there's some like like how
does it feel to be a web server do 404s
hurt
not yet how would you know what
suffering looked like sure you can
recognize a suffering dog because we're
the same stack as the dog
all the biostack stuff kind of
especially mammals you know it's really
easy you can
game recognize this game yeah
versus the Silicon stack stuff it's like
you have no idea
you have you It Go wow the little thing
has learned to mimic
you know
but then I realized that that's all we
are too oh look the little thing has
learned to mimic yeah I guess uh yeah
404 could be could be suffering but it's
so far
from our kind of living organism our
kind of Stack but it feels like AI can
start
maybe mimicking the biological stack
better but about it because it's trained
we trained it yeah
and so in that maybe that's the
definition of Consciousness is the the
biostat Consciousness the definition of
Consciousness is how close something
looks to human sure I'll give you that
one no how close something is to The
Human Experience sure
it's a very it's very anthropocentric
definition but well that's all we got
sure no and I I don't mean to like I
think there's a lot of value in it look
I just started my second company my
third company will be AI girlfriends
no like Arena I want to find out what
your fourth company is oh wow because I
think once you have ai girlfriends it's
uh
oh boy
does it get interesting
well maybe let's go there I mean the
relationships with AI That's creating
human-like organisms right
and part of being human is being
conscious is being uh having the
capacity to suffer having the capacity
to experience this leveragely in such a
way that you can empathize
the AIS is going to empathize with you
and you can empathize with it or you can
project your uh anthropomorphic sense of
what the other entity is experiencing
and an AI model would need to um yeah to
create that experience inside your mind
and it doesn't seem that difficult yeah
but okay so here's where it actually
gets totally different right
when you interact with another human you
can make some assumptions
yeah when you interact with these models
you can't you can make some assumptions
that that other human experiences
suffering and pleasure in a pretty
similar way to you do the golden rule
applies
with an AI model this isn't really true
right these these large language models
are good at fooling people because they
were trained on a a whole bunch of human
data and told to mimic it yep but if if
the AI system says hi my name is
Samantha
has a backstory yeah I went to college
here and there yeah maybe you'll
integrate this in AI system I made some
chat Bots I give him backstories it was
lots of fun I was so happy when llama
came out yeah well we'll talk about long
we'll talk about all that but like you
know the rock with the smiley face yeah
why this it seems pretty natural for for
you to anthropomorphize that thing and
then start dating it and before you know
it you're married and have kids with a
rock with a rock those pictures on
Instagram with you and a rock and smiley
face to be fair like you know something
that people generally look for when
they're looking for someone to date is
intelligence and some
form and The Rock doesn't really have
intelligence only a pretty desperate
person would date a rock
I think we're all desperate deep down oh
not rock level desperate all right uh
not rock level
desperate but AI level desperate I don't
know I think all of us have a deep
loneliness it just feels like the
language models are there
oh I agree and you know what I won't
even say this so cynically I will
actually say this in a way that like I
want AI friends I do yeah like I would
love to you know again I the language
models now are still a little like
people are impressed with these GPT
things and I look at like or or like or
uh the the co-pilot the coding one and
I'm like okay this is like Junior
engineer level and these people are like
Fiverr level artists and copywriters
like okay great we got like Fiverr and
like Junior Engineers okay cool like and
this is just a start and it will get
better right like I would I can't wait
to have ai friends who are more
intelligent than I am so Fiverr is just
a temporary it's not the ceiling no
definitely not
is it uh is it count as cheating
when you're talking to an AI model
emotional cheating
that's that's up to you and your human
partner to Define oh you have to all
right you can yeah you have to have to
have that conversation I guess all right
I mean integrate that with uh with porn
and all this I don't know I mean a
similar kind of to porn yeah yeah
right I think people in relationships
have different views on that
yeah but most people don't have like
serious open conversations about
all the different aspects of what's cool
and what's not
and it feels like AI is a really weird
conversation to have
the porn one is a good branching off
like these things you know one of my
scenarios that I put in my chatbot is I
uh you know uh
a nice girl named Lexi she's 20. she
just moved out to LA she wanted to be an
actress but she started doing only fans
instead and you're on a date with her
enjoy
oh man yeah and so was that if you're
actually dating somebody in real life is
that cheating
I feel like it gets a little weird sure
it gets real weird it's like what are
you allowed to say to an AI bot imagine
having that conversation with a
significant other I mean these are all
things for people to Define in their
relationships what it means to be human
is just gonna start to get weird let's
pushing it online like how do you know
like there'll be moments when you'll
have what you think is a real human you
interacted with on Twitter for years and
you realize it's not
I spread I love this meme uh Heaven
Banning do you think about Shadow
Banning yeah right Shadow Banning okay
you post no one can see it Heaven
Banning you post no one can see it but a
whole lot of AIS are spun up to interact
with you
well maybe that's the way human
civilization ends is all of us a Heaven
band there's a great uh it's called My
Little Pony Friendship is optimal it's a
Sci-Fi story that uh explores this idea
friendship is optimal friendship is
optimal yeah I'd like to have some at
least stuff on the intellectual realm
some AI friends that argue with me
but the the Romantic realm is weird
definitely weird
but
not out of the realm of uh
the uh the kind of weirdness that human
civilization is capable of I think I
think I want it look I want it if no one
else wants it I want it yeah I think a
lot of people probably want it there's a
deep loneliness
and I'll fill their loneliness and you
know it just will only advertise to you
some of the time yeah maybe the
conceptions of monogamy change too like
I grew up in a time like I value
monogamy but maybe that's a silly notion
when you have
arbitrary number of AI systems yeah this
this um this interesting path from
rationality to polyamory yeah that
doesn't make sense for me for you but
you're just a biological organism it was
born before
like read the internet really took off
the crazy thing is like culture is
whatever we Define it as right these
things are not you like is a lot problem
in moral philosophy right there's no
like like okay what is might be that
like computers are capable of mimicking
uh you know girlfriends perfectly they
pass the girlfriend Turing test right
but that doesn't say anything about a
lot that doesn't say anything about how
we ought to respond to them as a
civilization that doesn't say we ought
to get rid of monogamy right that's a
completely separate question really a
religious one
girlfriend touring test I wonder what
that looks like a girlfriend are you
writing that
uh will you be the the Alan touring of
the 21st century that writes the uh the
girlfriend touring test I mean of course
my my hey girlfriends their goal is to
pass the girlfriend Turing test no but
you there should be like a paper that
kind of defines the test
I mean the question is if it's deeply
personalized or there's a common thing
that really gets
everybody
yeah I mean you know look we're a
company we don't get everybody we just
have to get a large enough uh clientele
today well I thought you already already
thinking company